Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Is Robin. And we are once again,
setting our sights on taking out the mightiest beings in the universe as our
series on how to kill superheroes focuses on one of the strongest characters and
DC comics, John Jones, better known as Martian Manhunter.
So how to kill Martian? Manhunter set him on fire.
They should watching guys hearse.
Now, before.
We figure out how to kill the Martian, Manhunter,
we're going to go over his origin and then take a look at his powers to see why
it's actually a lot harder to kill him than you believe it is.
So Marsha Manhunter was first created and appeared in detective comics.
Number 225 and 1955. Now,
as you probably guessed the Martian Manhunter hails from the planet of Pluto,
no, it's not actually a planet, a Martian Manhunter Hilson, the planet Mars,
where he served as one of the planet's law enforcement agents,
commonly known as man hunters. Now one day,
John is transported to earth by a beam built by scientists named Saul Earl who
dies a shock immediately upon seeing him. This was unfortunate for John as Dr.
Earl was the only one capable of operating the beam.
And so John was stuck on earth. Now on the plus side,
John's capable of shape-shifting.
And so he disguises himself as a human and adopts a human name,
which by a stroke of incredible luck happened to be the exact rhyme of his
martial name. So John begins a career as a detective and a superhero,
and would go on to be a founding member of the justice league of America.
Now his origin was rebooted when DC launched the new 52,
so that Jon Jones actually came to earth voluntarily to learn how to be alone,
which went against his Marsha nature. As the Martians, as a species,
we're all telepathically linked.
And so John needed to learn this skill so that he could lead the Martians.
But when he returned to his home planet,
he founded a desolate wasteland with no signs of life,
which led him to dedicate his life to exact revenge for his fallen people. Now,
as far as his powers go,
Martian Manhunter is one of the strongest characters in the DC universe.
And according to the JLA by grant Morrison is actually stronger than Superman.
His punches were able to harm super boy Pronto.
One of the most powerful versions of Superman to ever exist.
Subaru prime was also able to alter reality with his punches.
So the fact that Martian Manhunter was able to affect him is pretty freaking
impressive.
Now he's also able to fly at speeds that allow him to keep up with Superman and
the flash. He also possesses insane durability.
Having taken punches from some of DC's heaviest hitters,
as well as a regenerative healing factor that allows him to quickly recover from
whatever damage he sustains.
And so it's probably out of the question for us to overpower Martian Manhunter
or try to kill him,
do a purely physical means since he can take an insane amount of damage,
almost certainly more than we'll be able to dish out. Now,
in addition to a superhuman physical characteristics,
Martian Manhunter can also shapeshift in whatever form you can imagine and can
alter the density of his body to be either super dense or intangible.
He's also among the strongest telepath in the DC universe with the ability to
read the mind of every single person on earth. At the same time,
he's also able to shoot powerful energy beams with a minced destructive power
from his eyes. And so bearing all this in mind,
we can see just how difficult killing the Martian Manhunter is because he's an
incredibly powerful character, but it's our job. So how do we do it? Well,
let's first address the answer.
That's probably obvious to anyone familiar with Martian Manhunter his
well-publicized weakness to fire.
This has been a staple of the character in some form or fashion for most of his
existence.
Now this is time has been depicted as vulnerability or weakness to fire,
and sometimes simply as a fear of fire.
And sometimes he's only vulnerable to fire. That's magical in nature.
His relationship with fire really just varies depending on who's riding him at
the time.
And I think currently he's suddenly just afraid of fire because the entire
Martian race was destroyed by it. He hasn't actually vulnerable to it,
but I'm sure when you clicked on this video,
the first thing that crossed your mind was just kill him with fire doc.
And I don't blame you guys for thinking that because it's the obvious answer.
And it would definitely work because we saw Marsha man Hunter kill with fire.
The first issue of final crisis in 2008, he was literally just set on fire.
And it was kind of funny, not overly funny, but kind of funny.
What was really funny with during tower Babel were like,
they go to the forest to try to find him Martian. Manhunter like,
there's a great, big, huge forest fire.
And he's just like running around screaming, being on fire.
It was a little comedic. It wasn't supposed to be, but it was,
I mean, I don't mean to say that.
I think it's funny a person being on fire and running around screaming.
That's not funny, but Martian Manhunter. It was funny.
He was also killed by Superman's heat vision in the injustice comics,
which aren't really in continuity.
The characters in that series seem to be pretty much equivalent to their main
universe counterparts, albeit their powers and strengths fluctuate a little bit.
And so this would also be a possible way to kill Martian Manhunter if we chose
to, and again,
referencing the tower of Babel that mans planned for Martian Manhunter was to
use fire. So if that's that man's plan,
we know it's going to be pretty much full-proof, but for this video,
I want to go beyond the obvious and be a little less cliche.
So is there anything other than fire that we can use to our advantage? Well,
it's commonly stated the fire is the only weakness Martian Manhunter has and
that he's in vulnerable otherwise, but is that true? Well, the answer is no,
there is one other substance to which Martian Manhunter has an acute weakness.
And although it's not as well-known as his weakness to fire,
it's still produced devastating effects and that substance is tacos. Now,
if you're not familiar with chocos,
they are a chocolate sandwich cookie that exists in the DC universe that are
very similar too,
but legally distinct from Oreos and Martian Manhunter is addicted to them.
Literally they have an addictive effect on Martians. In fact,
he loved them so much that booster gold and blue beetle played a prank on him by
buying up all the chocos from all the stores in the area,
and then just not giving them to them.
But this praise backfires in a major way as Martian Manhunter completely flips
out his shape-shifting goes out of control and he starts destroying the city.
And the longer he went without chocos the less than Tilden he became until he
was eventually just a mindless being destroying everything in his path.
Eventually he got some tacos and purse his body of the addiction,
but it then became a Cynthia and being that he had to destroy it,
it's kind of crazy. But anyway,
how can we use this to kill Martian Manhunter well, I don't know.
Maybe we can just sit a mountain of tacos in front of him and he'll eat so many
that his pancreas just shuts down. I mean,
do Martians have pancreases or maybe we just leave a trail of chocos that leads
him into a fire pit and yeah, that's technically using fire to kill him.
So in a way you probably didn't expect that when you clicked on this video and
that's what I'm going for here to come up with a fun and entertaining way to
kill your favorite superhero. That's the only thing I can really think of.
Right?
Like just have a trail of chocos that he's just like eating and then following
them. And he's like, Oh, he just burns alive and he dies. I'll be honest.
I would read that story. I think it'd be amazing, right? Like, like it's just,
it's just like a one-off right. DC showcase presents, tricking,
Martian Manhunter into like burning himself alive. It'd be amazing.
Would that being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you have a better way to kill Martian,
Manhunter posted down in the comment section. I would love to hear it and yeah,
I will.
[Inaudible].